et voilà qui nous amène à parler d'amour
si vous l'avez oublié il n'est pas trop
tard c'est la saint valentin des fleurs
des mots doux ou des chansons
impressions recueillies au fil de la
journée par françois jullien pieds-noirs
et guillaume viard ils sont tous très
amoureux des chansons d'edith piaf et
tous dans cette chorale ont connu un
jour l'amour pour premier amour 16
s'atteler pierre je suis très amoureuse
j'ai déjà été mariée deux fois je suis
en train d'amorcer le virage de
l'amoureux jusqu'à des traînées les
fleurs c'est périssable chantait
quelqu'un mais accompagnée d'une chanson
c'est tellement bon chez le fleuriste on
hésite cabrel piaf ou jacques brel du
sel
une c'est la tension qui compte six fait
la chance ça fera par plus pleuvoir mais
a préféré ça ne mérite pas de perdre
non rien de rien non je ne regrette vous
n'aurez traitez pas vous j'espère que
non ça sera à refaire tout
mais attention messieurs de ne pas vous
faire cueillir en ce jour de saint
valentin avec plus d'un bouquet dans les
mains
aujourd'hui effectivement vous avez le
veulent qu'ils viennent pour prendre
deux bouquets car pour leurs épouses
oh
coutu tamis et prennent aussi pour mes
traces officieuse on va dire aujourd'hui
les mots d'amour fleuri sur les panneaux
municipaux les mêmes maux ou presque
qu'il y a un siècle sur les cartes
postales des amoureux
réunis dans ce livre reçoit mon front
soit les plus douces caresses de tagab
et qui t'aime et qui pensent nuitées
jours à toi mais les histoires d'amour
finissent mal affirme une célèbre
chanson en général
heureusement il y a beaucoup
d'exceptions